- Gary Vee, welcome to The Mentor.
- Thank you for having me.
- Gary's in the house!
That's pretty cool.
- Yes.
- That's very cool for me,
let me tell you.
- Thank you.
- I'm a big fan of yours.
- Thank you so much.
- So, what we like to do
for our audience at least,
is that our audience
loves to know a little bit
about the person.
I mean, you know, you're a public figure.
Everybody probably
follows you on Instagram
and all the various other places
that you put out your material.
They probably don't get that
much time to hear really
about the Gary Vee story.
- Sure.
- Who is Gary Vaynerchuk?
I'd like to know.
- (sighing) You know,
- Tell me.
- It's a very classic
immigrant story, you know,
of a boy that's born in a
deeply communist country
like the Soviet Union, coming to America,
which is a very capitalist
country, in the late 70's.
Unfortunately there was
not a very good economy
at the time when we came,
so these golden streets
that my parents were promised
were even worse than they were in Russia.
So much so that some fun
stories have popped up recently
in my family of like,
even debating to go back.
- Seriously?
- Yeah.
Which was kinda interesting even for me.
So, it was a lot of struggle.
You know, I always tell a
lot of my friends that I'm
far more similar to their grandfather
than I am to them, 'cause I
was born in the old country.
Because I came over.
Because I worked all the time.
Because there was no entitlement.
School was kind of
almost weirdly secondary,
in a lot of ways.
- School in America, or school in...
- Yeah, school in America.
You know, I wasn't a good student.
And you know, for a lot of
second and third generations
school is the big play, but
for a lot of first generations
you're just trying to
put food on the table
and that's what my parents did,
but I was so intertwined
with them because I was born
in the old world.
And it was a very entrepreneurial story.
By the time I was six or seven years old
I was selling lemonade,
I was shoveling snow,
I was washing cars, I was selling flowers.
It was...
- What drove that?
Why, why?
- DNA.
There's nothing else.
- You didn't have to put
food on your own table?
- I did not, it was just
more fun for me than playing.
It was more fun for me when
snow would hit the ground
to go in the garage, grab a shovel
and ring people's door bells and say
I will shovel your driveway
for $5, than it was
to build a snowman or
sledding or throw snowballs
at each other.
- Was it a game?
- It continues to be a game.
- Yeah, so even then it was a game then?
- Hundred percent.
- Work was a game?
- Yes.
And an enjoyable game.
I think one of the reasons I'm successful
and one of the things I
try to push a lot of people
to think about is, can
you love your process?
You know, if you're in this,
and entrepreneurship is cool
now, if you're in this...
- Too cool.
That's exactly right.
If you're in this to flex on
Instagram you're gonna lose.
And I was doing it when it
was in the 80's and 90's
in America, entrepreneurship
wasn't a thing.
- In this country people
thought it was somethin' bad.
- And America too.
- You were a bad dude.
- If you're an entrepreneur
- Risk.
- you're actually a loser
living off of Mommy and Daddy.
You're exactly right.
You and I know this, a lot
of the kids don't know.
Now it's like being a
rapper or an athlete.
It's incredible for me to
watch what's transformed
over 30 years.
But I was willing to do it
because it's all I could do.
I listened to athletes,
actors and actresses, singers,
artists, and in their
documentaries inevitably
they're like, "Well I just
couldn't do anything else".
And as an entrepreneur that's how I think.
- You know, there's a lot of
hard luck stories that
I hear around the world.
Mike Tyson's a good example.
He had nothin' and he
used sport as his way out.
Do you think entrepreneurship
is a way out?
- You know, I think--
- Then, back then.
- I think it is for some, I do.
I don't think it was for me.
I didn't feel desperate, I didn't grow up
in an environment that scared me.
- [Host] Didn't you have choices?
- I did have choices, to be frank, I did.
I could've decided to be a good student.
I just loved it.
I love it now.
I love it.
I mean, on the flight here from the US,
I woke up 1 a.m. Sydney time,
knowing that it was probably
in my best interests to
sleep a little bit more
to get on time here, but I
was so happy that I woke up
because I couldn't wait
to go on eBay and look up
the value of sports cards,
because in the last month,
and really over the last
year but in the last month,
I've gotten white hot in the theory that
sports cards are about to make a comeback,
and I wanna buy up as many
soccer and basketball cards
as I can, 'cause I think
they're gonna go up a bunch.
That's an energy that, and
I'm gonna make no money,
I'll make more money speaking
in this four city tour
during this week than I
will in the countless hours
I put in over the next
year, trying to buy up
Messi rookie cards or LeBron rookie cards
but the action of the game, the,
something that nobody else saw.
I'm far more proud that I
saw social media, Facebook,
Twitter, those things,
than the money I made
by making those bets.
- Can I ask you something?
You're an intense dude.
- Yes. (chuckles)
- You are.
That's cool, I'm similar,
but in a different way.
And a lot of people don't like it, okay?
But I can just see you talking about
just like the cards now.
What is it in the fabric
of Gary Vaynerchuk's life,
you're going to say it's in your DNA,
but what is it that in
your social development
that actually was formed all the layers
to get you to be so intense?
Because you can't be good at what you do
unless you're intense.
You gotta love it, get it,
but you gotta be intense.
- I think--
- Think intensely.
- I think...
Being on your own, you know.
Not having the luxury,
which I think is a disadvantage,
of an over-coddling nature.
- [Host] What does that
mean, doing it on your own?
- You know, as soon as I was
four, five, six years old
I'm outside playing by myself.
- No brothers and sisters?
- I did, but you know, they
were three years younger
and eleven years younger,
so at first it's me.
So, no brothers and sisters.
A mother that grew up in the Soviet Union
where the framework was
go outside and play.
The 80's when you could
still do that in America.
So, crossing the street,
playing in the woods,
I mean, there's 15 year
olds that are being watched
by their parents more than I
was watched when I was five.
- Fucking kills me.
- Of course it kills you,
'cause you know exactly
the vulnerability.
We're living in a time where
everyone's a zoo animal.
They don't know how to live
in society 'cause parents
are such helicopters. and
eighth place trophies,
and nobody's allowed to lose,
nobody's allowed to cry.
- I saw that on Instagram,
10th place
- Saw that?
(host mumbles)
So, for me, I think what's in
my fabric is, having to scrap.
I'm from the dirt.
I had no choice.
I fight.
- And does that build
your intensity though?
- Of course.
- And does it ever wear you out?
- Not for me.
You know, I'm empathetic
that it might be too much for others.
I respect that.
I understand that, I just
also can't live my life
based on other people's judgment.
- Is Mum or Dad energetic like that?
- You know, in different ways yes.
But, neither like come
across in the way that I do.
I think I'm a pretty
interesting blend of the two.
I'm much more of a showman and
high-energy than my father,
but I'm deeply competitive
and in the work ethic.
My mom is not a showman either
but her side of the family
is, especially the men.
So, no, you know, I'm
different than both my parents.
But obviously 'cause it's
so easy for me to read,
I understand the pieces
of the puzzle that I got
from both of them to how this happened.
- Are they proud of you?
- Oh, immensely.
- How important is that to you?
- Oh, unbelievably.
I'm a uncomfortable
advocate of my parents.
I'm a deeply grateful child.
I mean I'm writing a book in my own head
that I eventually will put out
called "Perfectly Parented".
You know, most people hate their parents
or dwell on their parents,
which is probably not true
but spend a lot of time judging
what their parents did wrong,
instead of thinking about
what their parents did right.
I'm sure my parents did
tons of things wrong,
I'm just incapable of focusing on that,
I'm just so grateful for
the things they did right.
- There's a lot of people out
there, I mean, you're a doer.
The intensity brings
effort and with intensity
you get a lotta execution.
But, were you a dreamer as a kid?
Did you sit around dreaming?
'Cause I mean, you're gonna sell lemonade
or whatever you're gonna do.
Did you sit down and plan it?
Like you woke up one--
- Yes.
- thinking about your cards.
Did you do that as a kid?
- (sighing) Only in the most macro level.
I very early on decided
that I was gonna buy
my favorite football
team, the New York Jets.
And I've stuck to it for
35 years at this point.
So, yeah, I would say I dreamt about that.
I dreamt about making a
mark in the wine business
and building one of the large
retail companies in America.
I did that.
I dreamt, I thought, about
disrupting the ad world
in a way that they couldn't see coming.
I'm putting the final
pieces on that right now.
So, I dream currently of
leaving an incredible legacy
and having thousands of
people show up to my funeral
because of the value I
provided with no ask in return.
So, yeah, I dream, I dream.
But, I'm too grounded in
practicality to be a talker.
You know, I would be embarrassed
to talk and not execute.
I almost put things
out to put the pressure
on making sure I execute,
so that nobody can ever play a clip,
'cause I record everything,
of, "You talked a big game
"but you couldn't do it".
Now, I'm fine, unbelievably fine
with not achieving my goals.
I'm not fine with not trying to.
- You gotta have a crack.
A good hard crack.
- Gotta have,
like, a real fucking crack.
- Yeah, totally.
- You know what I mean?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Like, one of the best cracks.
Like that I can feel.
I love losing, believe it
or not, because that means
I deserved it.
But, I love the way you
delivered that sentence.
It excited me.
A real crack, an all time
crack, a last breath fuck it
I did everything, I
went as hard as I could.
- There's nothing left.
I wish there was a couple
more years 'cause I'd still be
cracking it a hundred, but if this is it,
I don't want to regret.
And you have to be careful
because a lot of times
one part of your life you
may leave no regret you know,
I spend a lot of time
tryin' to be thoughtful
of not being a man of the
world, at the expense of
my own children.
You see that a lot.
I read a lot of obituaries,
I watch a lot of famous
or people of notoriety
pass and the world mourns
but their kids have
very subtle interesting,
"Yeah, Dad was awesome to the world,
"we wish we had a little...", you know.
I read it.
I read it because I
inherently understand it
and I wanna hedge against
it, because I wanna find
the right balance.
I'm aware of it.
But yes, that's how I see it.
- A lot of people would like,
you get 'em all the time,
they are dreamers.
I mean, I've seen you
interview some of the people
at some of your talks, you know.
God love 'em, they get up
there and they want you
to solve a problem for 'em.
They ask you a question and
they looking for an answer.
And I see these dreamers.
What do you say to them
about balancing a difference
between dreaming and execution?
How do people work out, because
you gotta dream hard a lot,
and then you gotta stop, and
you gotta start executing
hard a lot, then you
gotta go back to dream.
'Cause your life can't
be just about executing,
it's gotta be about dreaming.
- That's right.
- It can't just be
- Yeah, you have
- about dreaming.
- to strategize.
and execute.
- How do you do that?
Without people saying you
change your mind all the time?
- First of all, I think
changing your mind all the time
is the core strength of a human being.
- People say to me and I
say, I'm just reassessing
what I'm doin'.
- My dad used to get so mad at me.
"You just said a week ago
that we were gonna sell rose".
I'm like, "I changed my mind.
"Customers came in, I
didn't like the way it felt.
"I changed my mind".
I think changing your
mind is a huge strength.
It's funny, I was about to
answer and we brought up
the change your mind, I
think it's the same thing.
I think a lot of people don't fire people,
don't change their mind 'cause
they're greatly insecure.
This is an enormous game of insecurity.
You know, why do people dream and not do?
They're insecure.
They inherently don't
think they can do it.
- The system makes us a bit that way too.
I don't know about in America,
but in this country here,
our regulatory environment--
- Yes.
- sort of enhances this
insecurity, which puts you
in a position where you
can't fire somebody.
- Yeah, fuck that!
- Mate...
I got some of my guys here...
- I'm a lot more educated
in the UK version,
and I'm aware that the Australian
version's closer to that.
That is some fucking horseshit.
And is the great vulnerability to,
anything that eliminates merit is bad.
If somebody sucks and you can't fire them,
the whole thing's broken.
- Yeah, totally.
- The hell are we doing here?
- I mean I battle with it
all the time, it kills me
and like I even did a
TV show here about it
where I actually had
to say, "You're fired",
and it's not very Australian to do that.
Because it's considered
uncool to fire somebody.
But in my business, I'm
sorry, I just can't put up
with something that doesn't work.
- More importantly leads to entitlement
and entitlement is poison.
A hundred percent.
- We just had a chat about
what sort of drove Gary.
Look, one thing, I wanna talk about
some practical stuff now,
'cause we got a lotta listeners
who are desperate to
emulate people like you.
People actually love you.
I talk to 'em, I been
talking to a lot of people,
since you were gonna come on the show.
Everybody just raps, raps,
raps, and I've been following
what's goin' on at the three
states you talking about
on the NAC, National Achievers Convention.
And I've been watching all the videos.
Everyone's saying "Great stuff".
But, where do you advise people to say...
"Look, this is not just
about me having followers
"and people loving me".
That's important, but
what do you say to people,
how do you actually
turn it into a business?
Otherwise you're just wasting your time.
- (sighing) So, I think
there's a lot of ways to do it.
You know, it's really funny,
you and I are super
aligned with this, which is
at the end of the day,
things have to become practical, you know.
And during the break I
was saying, you know,
you don't pay your bills with followers.
And I believe that.
I'm also a very interesting
messenger when it comes to this
because unlike many of my
contemporaries that kind of
look like me, one of the core
reasons everybody loves me
is I don't actually extract
value out of my audience.
Now, couple of things,
there is nothing wrong
with extracting value
out of your audience.
This is the free world,
nobody has to buy your program
or your offsite or your master, you know.
So, what's interesting about
what I do is I build businesses
that don't have to do
with my audience, right?
So, VaynerMedia works with
Fortune 5000 companies.
You know, so my audience
is not the CEO of GE.
- So, can you connect the two then?
Can you connect the audience
back to...
- I think the way I,
you know, it's really interesting
how I connect the audience.
Let me give you an example.
It is very clear to me that
we have one to two clients
at VaynerMedia right now that are, client.
That I would argue that the tipping point
to why they chose VaynerMedia versus,
is because their 17 year old
son of the decision-maker
thinks I'm cool.
Brand.
Got it?
- Yeah.
- But, it's funny, let me
go here, because I think
this will bring value to the audience.
I wrote a book several years
ago that did extremely well,
called "Jab, Jab, Jab, Right Hook".
I thought I was writing
it for the opposite
of who we're talking to.
This enormous group of
people on the internet
who only sell.
Buy this, buy that, have
no interest in value.
Only wanna do top of the
funnel in landing pages,
just to convert you to their $900 eBook.
No soul, really gross.
And I was trying to teach 'em,
like, "Hey, take a step back.
"How about a little romance?
"You don't have to try to close
at the bar at every move".
- Can I buy you a drink first?
- You know, not even that,
you know what I mean.
Like half these characters on the internet
are just like right at it.
So, I was hey, jab, jab, jab.
Give it some value, give
some value, give some value,
then ask, don't expect.
What was interesting
is that's who I thought
I was doing it for.
What had ended up happening
was it was actually
who you're going for.
The people that most responded to the book
were people who were super ideological,
and actually were very
frothy and almost hippy-like.
Building great content,
bringing so much value,
but were actually scared
to go in for the sale.
You know, my great ability to
both be selfish and selfless,
in balance, in harmony,
pulling hard from both sides,
has a lot to do with
what's working for me.
So, you know, listen,
at the end of the day,
vanity metrics, whether
that's followers on Instagram,
whether that's the
jewelry or car you drive,
no matter what it is,
at the end of the day,
underneath all of that,
there needs to be something
tangible and real, and if
you're not asking for business,
and more importantly if
you're not selling something
you believe in, you're finished.
The single reason I think
I'm a great salesman,
as somebody who hates to ask for a sale,
is 'cause I deeply believe
in what I'm selling.
Whether it's the wine I produce,
whether it's a sneaker
collaboration I have with K-Swiss,
whether it's Vayner.
Do you know what it feels
like to sit in this room
and know, fuck think,
know that VaynerMedia's
the best marketing firm in the world?
It's empowering!
You sell with conviction!
I just watch way too many people
either be deeply insecure
about what they're selling
'cause deep down they know
they have no idea what the fuck
they're selling...
- Besides that they don't know
what they're selling.
- That's right.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Or, they're just broken.
They just so care about
money, they know exactly
what they're selling,
they just know they're selling bullshit,
and they're fucking
praying on people's fears,
and I wanna kill those fuckers.
- Well it's funny you know,
I always talk about this whole point like,
you know, I'm in a home loan business,
and I was in a home loan
business many years ago
with a well-known person in Australia.
And he once said to me,
and I was a young guy,
and I was trying to get him
to buy half my business.
He asked me the question,
'cause if I had to invest,
you know, in those days a lot of money,
$25 million into my business.
He said to me, "What business are you in?"
and I was about to say I'm
in the home loan business
'cause my company was
called Wizard Home Loans.
(Gary chuckles)
He said, "Don't say fuckin' home loans".
And I was stuffed, I
don't know what to say.
And he said to me, he gave me the answer,
he said, "You're not selling home loans
"you're selling people's
hopes and dreams".
- That's right.
- He said
that's what your messaging is.
That's what I love doing, you know.
Even today, my other
business sells home loans
we still do home loans,
and I was only thinking about
it today, when I was coming
down to the studio.
I actually love lending people
money to buy a fuckin' house.
You know, I love lending money to people
- That's cool.
- because they get
so happy.
And that's like, if my
branches around Australia
put up on Instagram a photograph
of them standing there
next to someone who's just,
with their wife and kids,
whatever their arrangements
are, in front of a sold sign
with a key, just about walk in the house,
that's the best feeling I can get.
- When you're selling hopes and dreams,
and it's practical, that's amazing.
Unfortunately a lot of
people sell the other way.
They sell against people's--
- Bullshit.
- They sell against people's
insecurities and fears.
- Yeah, some bullshit.
- I hate it!
There's a great thing that
somebody said to me years ago
and I say it all the time,
there's two ways to build
the biggest building in town,
you either just build the
biggest building in town,
or you spend all your time
tearing everybody else's building down.
And I think about it
often, maybe once a week.
And if there's anything,
on my last breath,
that I'm most proud of, is I'm out here
just trying to build the biggest building.
I have no interest in
tearing anybody else's
building down, and watching
other people navigate
the other way, is
intriguing for me to watch,
and honestly I feel bad
for them because I know
there's real poison inside that system.
- Can I ask you something
about sport?
- Yeah. Sure.
- For me, sport's really important.
Not just it's the fabric of my life,
but it's also something that drives me,
I always look to sport in
terms of my own businesses
et cetera.
But I can't live without sport.
And I've seen some YouTube stuff of you
getting involved in sport,
training with a lot of people you know,
that look like they might be baseballers
or footballers over there.
How important is sport to you?
What's it do for your life?
- Well first of all,
the reason I love sports
is there's no hiding.
It's why I love boxing,
and you brought up Mike Tyson earlier.
Man, I like boxing.
There's just no hiding,
you know?
- Yep, I do know.
- You know what I hate about business?
There's a lotta hiding.
You put "entrepreneur"
on your bio on Instagram,
and everyone thinks you are one, you know.
And so, sport's important
to me because I love
when it goes to triple zero,
somebody won and somebody lost.
Both of us already reacted in this podcast
around the thought of
like, eighth place trophies
are not that.
So that's important, me.
Physically I love to compete, you know.
You know, like if you said
lets run to the door right now,
you'd be stunned what I
would do, like I'd (mumbles),
whatever it takes.
I love, the game.
As far as physical fitness,
about five to six years ago
I took it very seriously,
after not taking it seriously
most of my life, and it's
been a great addition.
Especially soft tissue
work, my back I hurt,
during the liquor store days.
It's been very important, but
it doesn't release stress.
I'm always fascinated by
people that work out, or run,
or do sports, where they speak about
the mental stress relief.
For some reason I don't have that.
But what I love is the merit.
God, I wish everything in life was sports,
because it's just so cool.
You can't cheat.
You know, people can talk about steroids
and enhancement drugs, fine.
It's a really pure reality,
and I love that.
- Does it form part of your routine now?
I mean everyone will say,
"Well what does Gary Vee do
"when he gets up in the morning?"
But like, what's your routine?
In terms of sport.
- Yeah, I mean I work out every day.
I go to the gym.
So that's what I do.
- What sort of sport is it?
We talking about running, we
talking about lifting weights?
- Yep.
Mainly lifting weights,
a lotta soft tissue work.
That is something that I've become,
fascia and all this, incredibly
game-changing for the way,
some of the flaws I had.
I play basketball though,
you know, at 43 it's starting
to get to a place where
I'm a little worried
about knees and ankles
and things of that nature.
I play a little tennis.
I don't do as much competitive sport
as I'd probably like to.
But it is something I think a lot about,
of how to interject it a
little bit more into my world.
- Do you think it's, an an entrepreneur,
as somebody who's sort of
running their own business,
and you know, there is a lotta
shit you have to deal with.
For me it's like meditating.
That's my hour,
- That's where I was going
- hour and a half.
- with this earlier.
I don't get that.
- You don't get that?
- No.
- You still thinking about
work, even when you training?
- No, but...
Maybe?
What I would say is
not always.
- You maybe not trained
fuckin' hard enough.
Come on, you must come
- Listen--
- to a session after this--
- I think you appreciate this.
I'm fucking doing everything hard.
- Yeah, I get it.
- It's just, you know,
it's funny, I'm gonna answer it this way,
and I've been thinking a lot about it
for the last four years,
as meditation has grown
in popularity, which is great
because I love seeing people
find balance in the tactic.
I would argue that I'm
meditating at all times.
- Well, that's cool then.
- And I don't know what
exactly I'm saying right now,
but intuitively,
man I feel super,
like I'm almost having a
conversation with myself
while I'm having one with you.
Yeah, I don't know what it is.
I'm very grateful for it.
I'm in really interesting
harmony and balance.
I'm in a very funny framework.
I'm basically in one place.
If eight people didn't die
today, everything else is good.
I've gotten very, I don't know
if that was my great-grandmother,
my grandmother was very
Russian thing, like every
single thing we bless too.
Everything was health, health.
You know, everybody
died so young in Russia.
It was a miserable place.
Alcoholism at scale, communism's bad.
But I'm pretty much in the
place of I don't need that much
of a mental release from my
work, I actually am not that
anxious about it.
- I was gonna say
is it because, is
everything going good then?
- Yeah, but even when it's going bad,
I don't think I like money.
- Do you have bad times, in your work?
- Only time I have bad times
is when I have to hurt somebody
by firing them, you know?
Like, I hate that.
But like, when somebody's
firing, you should see me
on a phone call or a meeting,
getting fired by a client.
It is hilarious.
They start it, I know
exactly what's happening,
and I basically bail them
out within five seconds.
- Fuckin' hurry up with it.
- But in a sweet way.
Full accountability, don't worry.
You know like...
- I'm out of here.
- Yeah.
I need the 18 minutes
back, to go, you know--
- How do you fire someone
then, in your environment?
What do you say to 'em?
- This has been the great--
- How many chances
do you give 'em?
- Oh, I give them too many.
I would argue, for as much
as I hate entitlement,
I'm very good at creating
it within my workforce.
But I've gotten a lot better.
I really needed the lesson
of this last company.
Somewhere around year six of
VaynerMedia I looked around
and said, oh fuck.
Everything I despise I've created.
I've over-coddled this organization,
I've put too much on my shoulders
and my deep anger and dislike for conflict
has created entitlement.
And I had to go through a
recourse, and the entitled kids
weren't ready for it.
And it was painful.
Radical candor is not something
that came natural to me.
I, stun you my firing you and
giving you a great severance
than giving you critical
feedback along the way.
It was just my framework
and it's something
I've had to work on.
I'm a much stronger operator today.
Today, I had a couple
conversations last month
that I just can't even believe
I'm the one having them.
I'm being so transparent,
I'm not over-coddling it,
I'm not sugar-coating it.
And it's super unnatural for me.
I do not like micro conflict.
I'm a tough guy on video and the stage,
but when it comes to one-on-one,
I'm a honey over vinegar guy.
But I've had to get better,
and I want to be better
and so, I've gotten, the
conversations have become
far more transparent.
One thing that I struggle with
is feedback from other managers
'cause I think they're incentivized
to undermine their own direct reports.
So, I'm quite cynical to senior management
giving me feedback on
people underneath them.
So the reason people get a lot of chances
is 'cause I don't make the
mistake that most people do,
which is blindly take the
word of their direct report
as an indicator, because
I actually think they have
more to lose and sometimes suppress
the people underneath them.
- 'Cause the big question
I get asked all the time
how do you deal with this?
So, are you saying to me then, you'll go
to the individual who, you
go past the direct report,
the boss, the manager, and
you go to the individual
and go and suss it out for yourself?
- Not only do I do
that, I follow everybody
on social media, I read Slack,
I'm doing a lot of recon
to make sure I have a clear
picture because I think
most people's vulnerability at scale
is they blindly take the information
from the most senior person,
who inherently has more to lose,
and I think leads to bad behavior.
- For me, I will not cop
it, but upward management?
So, in other words you're
my boss, I'm managing you
on your expectations of me...
- It gets a little fluffy there.
Not necessarily that, but not blind belief
that the manager said this person sucks.
I'm like, "Yeah, let's see about that".
- What I'm shitty about
actually, I'm gonna tell you
right now, why I'm really
fucking pissed off,
is we have to finish.
(Gary laughing)
I don't mind telling you
that, but I know you're on
a tight schedule.
So, I'm gonna ask you,
this is a really important question to me.
When Gary Vaynerchuk retires
or goes off into the sunset
and goes in his, you know,
next door to Richard Branson,
what do you want to be remembered for?
- That I gave more than I took.
I really want to be remembered for that.
- It's interesting when I
watch you, I see you are
very generous, actually
at a massive speed,
when you speak on YouTube
and various other places.
I was actually curious,
is that generosity?
Is that you wanting to
give more than you take,
or more than you receive?
And, do you think that
you've achieved that so far?
- Yeah.
- If you stop today?
- I think so.
I think that the thing that
alpha winners like you,
that are very close to me
and know a lot of details
are surprised by, is how much
I'm not driven by the thing
that most, I share many
things with many of you,
but, I just am not in it
for the things that I thought
I was in it as a kid.
What ended up happening
was, being a millionaire
or a billionaire, I'm just
not in it for the money.
I'll take it, I want it.
I wanna buy The Jets, but
fuck, I would much rather
be known who I am versus others.
I could easily get The Jets.
If I could switch to being
a more selfish individual.
I don't know if anybody
can extract more value
out of humans than me.
It just, I got very lucky,
in my opinion, that that
is not my framework, and
I enjoy the admiration
versus the extra zero on my bank account.
- Well for me that's really refreshing.
I love that answer, that's fantastic.
And I have to say, the people
listening to this show,
when Gary walked in,
I expected like an Anthony Robins moment
with like lots of noise,
and he came in very humble,
and he introduced himself to
everybody in the cast here,
everybody.
And to me, in our country
at least, that's refreshing
and that's very Australian, for us.
And I appreciate it.
- Thank you for saying that.
- Thank you very much
Gary Vaynerchuk.
- Thank you so much
for saying that.
- It's been awesome.
- Real pleasure.
(chilled music)